[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan we've heard it
a thousand times there's no money in art
it's too risky
you'll starve to death
so we end up chasing more stable careers
we become lawyers and engineers and
operations managers instead of writers
and filmmakers and painters
we settle
remember ryan we certainly settled in
our 20s oh yeah what do we settle for we
settled for a nice corporate career a
nice uh ladder to climb up but
unfortunately um
yeah we climbed high enough we were like
wait a minute this is the wrong ladder
and what you're talking about makes me
think about how when you decided to get
off that ladder
and uh people went to josh and they're
like what are you gonna do man like are
you going to like a competitor can i go
with you because you know it wasn't just
him and i that hated our you know jobs
in our company but
he said no i'm gonna go be a writer
and they were like a writer you can't
just go and be a writer
and you proved them all wrong melbourne
well that's what i want to talk to you
about today maybe we don't have to
choose between a creative life
and a prosperous life today on the
public podcast we're talking about
earning a living from your creative
pursuits and we're going to do that with
our guest today his name is jeff goins
he's the writer of this book which came
out a few years ago it's called real
artists don't starve i'll hold this up
if you're watching it on youtube jeff
thanks for coming here today yeah
happy to be here
thank you
uh good to be here thanks it's been a
long time that we've known each other
digitally yes and i'm happy to meet you
in person yeah likewise this thursday on
the minimalist private podcast we're
also going to talk to jeff about how to
be more creative we're talking about
creativity for uncreative people you can
check that out at patreon.com the
minimalist so just click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
jeff this is a listener driven show so i
thought i'd dive right in we're going to
be referencing your book quite a bit
today with some of these questions let's
start with a question from facebook
bjuster has a question for us
my daughter has been a professional
musician for 10 years and holds a
master's degree in her instrument but
she just scrapes by even with a second
job why do talented people still
struggle
now jeff what i was hoping to do is i
have your book here and i just want to
throw some passages at you and maybe
have you expand on them it's been a
while since you wrote the book so i
think you might even have new answers as
well so with buster's question i uh have
this little pithy saying from your book
you say all artists have a secret weapon
stubbornness
so
her daughter
has been stubborn enough to keep going
she didn't give up even though it may
not be paying the bills
fully so maybe we can talk about that a
little bit
sure um
so the premise of the book is being a
starving artist today is a choice not a
necessary condition of doing creative
work
and
what that means is
not that if you're starving that it's
your fault or you did anything wrong you
just might be missing something and so
the book is these 12 different
strategies that artists have been using
for 500 years going back to michelangelo
who was the richest artist of the
renaissance and after him he did
something
which i thought was interesting he did
something that no artist had done before
him and after him during the renaissance
there were many wealthy and affluent
artists so he changed the game and so i
began to understand what michelangelo
got into i was like well like what's up
with that and is this a pattern and can
you see it in the lives of other
successful creative people
and i think you can and the book is full
of i don't know
50 100 stories and one of the tools is
stubbornness and the story that i tell
in that chapter is of f scott fitzgerald
who obviously is the author of the great
gatsby one of the best-selling books of
all time
and and he's kind of known as this like
tortured alcoholic starving artist kind
of guy now it was not starving i mean if
you know anything about the fitzgeralds
they lived
well i don't know helpfully but well you
know jumping into fountains you know
renting out the penthouse of the ritz
carlton whatever hedonistic yes that's
right yeah which is my definition for
well
i mean you know whatever um
he made the equivalent of 500 000
per year as a working writer he was a
wealthy writer it wasn't just from his
books i mean most of his money came from
writing articles for
saturday evening posts you know those
kinds of publications
so uh before he became the author we
know him as today
uh he made a decision similar to you
josh where he was in the military just
like you were yeah
i mean it felt like the military
sometimes
it was militant yeah
and he fell in love with this uh
southern belle named zelda
and um
and she was rich and and he was like
i've got to make a lot of money and he
kept asking her to marry him and she
kept turning him down
and he
uh left the military and started writing
and he moved to new york city and he
started
submitting
lots of uh queries to magazines
newspapers for articles he was trying to
be a writer he was failing
and he submitted over a hundred articles
that all got failed
that all got rejected they all failed
and he lined his tiny little apartment
with those rejection letters like
wallpaper yeah and he was committed
because he met a beautiful woman and you
know muses still work to this day and um
he would not give up
and
the story goes that he
uh the day that his first book was
published uh they got married and
uh you know it was it was tumultuous
after that but what's interesting about
fitzgerald is he actually kind of forgot
his stubbornness and there's there's an
interesting thing about stubbornness
because most artists are stubborn about
the wrong things
you can't make it you guys know this
you can't make it if you're picky about
everything yeah and and if you're picky
about and you can't make it if you're
not picky about anything uh jeff bezos
actually has this um great quote about
when he started amazon he said we are
stubborn on vision flexible on details
most artists i find are the opposite
because you're an artist because you can
see the nuance in everything you go ah
no that's the wrong lighting i mean we
were doing it as we were setting this
scene up right you're like everything's
got to be just right and those details
matter but we could have spent two hours
adjusting everything right right and so
most artists i find especially who are
amateurs are stubborn on the details and
if you're stubborn on the details you
have no vision you can't see
you know 20 years in front of you so
what happened with fitzgerald was he was
determined i'm going to be a writer i'm
going to find a way i'm going to make it
happen and then when he was writing
gatsby his arguably his greatest work
um he got lost in the details and that
book is incredible that book was a
kind of a failure
i mean it sold about 20 000 copies uh in
its lifetime which is fine for a book
you know um but it wasn't the success
that he was used to
and and that kind of started his
downward spiral i mean he died of a
heart attack when he was 40 years old
and
a few years after
his death uh during world war ii
they invented this thing called a
paperback
and they started shipping books to
soldiers out uh you know in in the field
and the you know out
you know killing people killing nazis i
don't know what they're doing and but
but you know like it was a morale
booster they were sending out
um
uh books and and fitzgerald have had
enough friends in publishing that they
said
that this is a short book we can print
it as a paperback and and they sent it
out to soldiers in the field and you
know a few years after that it became
this big bestseller they started putting
it into high schools and so it's
interesting i know that's kind of a
long-winded answer to a question but
what's interesting about fitzgerald is
what started his career was stubbornness
he had a stubborn vision i'm gonna be a
writer i'm gonna marry zelda i'm gonna
have to make a lot of money because
this chick has expensive tastes you know
she's used to mansions and stuff and and
he did it but then what happened in his
work and this happens a lot with uh
musicians visual graphic artists writers
is you get lost in the nuance of your
work
there there's things in that book that i
don't like yeah you know there are
things that i regret writing or
decisions that i made when i was making
it
but we wouldn't be here today if i
didn't go
okay you know like i'm gonna ship it i'm
gonna put it out into the world he got
lost in the details and he got stubborn
about the details he lost his vision
and he died here this is a really sad
part of fitzgerald's story uh at the end
of his life he knew gatsby was his
greatest work
so much that he questioned every single
decision about it he hated the title he
wanted to call it
like the high bounding lover or
something
it's terrible it's like a nickname
it was real bad but he was you know what
that's like yeah you know what it's like
to get lost in a thing that you're
creating i did this yesterday that
everything feels like do or die
and that thinking that mindset will kill
you right the best thing that an artist
can do is make a lot of stuff and never
say this is my this is my greatest work
that'll kill you it actually killed
fitzgerald
and he got estranged from his wife who
went crazy he he became a
very bad alcoholic
and
at the end of his life he would go into
bookstores
use bookstores and he would buy copies
of his own book
just so that they would keep selling it
because you guys know your your authors
you go into a book store and the more
copies you buy from books or the more
they order that was the same then
and what's so interesting about him
is he died before he ever became one of
the world's best selling authors that
book very gatsby sells 500 000 copies on
a bad year every single year it was
published in the 20s
um
and what's interesting about him
is
if he had just been stubborn enough to
keep going
he would have seen incredible success of
his work and it's not true that what
made that book successful was that he
was an alcoholic starving suffering
artist that worked against him and so
ironically the thing he made was more
stubborn than he was and so if you want
to be an artist be stubborn but be
stubborn about the right things make a
lot of things don't get attached to too
many things what i love about blogging
which is why we're all here right yeah
is
it we're talking about improv comedy
before it's like it's that you don't
know
remember like writing a blog post and it
was okay
and like everybody loved it you're like
guys and remember like spending weeks on
one and like this is it and nobody care
books are that way too
so you've got to be stubborn enough to
succeed which means you've got to keep
giving yourself a lot of at-bats and
create for yourself a life that allows
you the opportunity to write a lot of
songs play a lot of shows write a lot of
books do a lot of things so that you can
see what sticks
i think that answers the first part of
this question really well the the second
part of buster's question is why do
talented people still
struggle and you've got this passage
from page 145 where you talk about you
don't just need
practice you also need a patron
and i think one of the reasons that we
often fails we have this expectation i'm
going to just create
but no one is supporting my work and it
actually takes a while to get people to
support your work or you may think that
you need
you know a million fans or even kevin
kelly's thousand true fans but in the
book you talk about maybe you just need
a
fan or follower supporter a patron yeah
by the way shout out to our patreon
supporters drop your comments in the uh
the chat the live chat here if you're
watching this live we'll get to your
questions here in a bit so for buster um
why do
why do
talented artists still struggle
because because i think that they're
actually stubborn about the details that
they don't have a vision
and um
and if they do
there's not some practical next step
um
you're right in that a lot of artists
i'm going to quit my job i'm going to
move to la i'm going to move to new york
or move to nashville whatever and i'm
going to go for it and like that's such
a bad way to approach
something that happens differently for
lots of people if you've burned all the
boats and burned all your bridges that's
a binary decision you will make it or
you will not
and you don't need to do that today
right like you can start writing books
on the side publishing them yourself uh
pretty easily like we've all done this i
remember you started you know
self-publishing these books because you
want to tell these stories right yeah
and it's really easy like it was even
easy then you know 10 years ago
and there are these incredible
opportunities to put your work out in
front of people and so many artists
believe this very old story i live in
nashville i remember about eight years
ago at a little coffee shop in franklin
tennessee right outside of nashville
and uh franklin is where all the rich
people who want to start families move
so i lived on the outskirts of that town
but i was i was working at a um at a
coffee shop and i was talking to my
agent about a book that i was working on
maybe this book i don't know and this
guy came up to me this is eight years
ago and
and he gives me his cd he goes hey um
i heard you talking about agents and
publishing and are you in are you in the
industry i go well i'm in an industry
in nashville if you go i'm a writer they
go what songs have you written right i
have to say author i'm an author and i
said you know i write books he goes do
you know anybody in the music industry
and i did because because it's a small
town and he goes could you
uh give this to somebody and i said sure
i'll give it to somebody now this is
this is nashville bible belt this was
dubstep christian worship music is what
that was i'm not kidding oh wow uh and
so he gives this is eight years ago not
a terribly long time ago he gives me a
cd
a cd yeah and i go yeah yeah yeah sure
man i'll whatever you know and i sit
down and even at this time my laptop
does not have a cd drive and i go i
don't know what to do with this
so
that is an example
of how artists are not using the
resources and technology and tools they
have available to them now they're
believing some old story they're they
watched walk the line and they're going
to go to memphis and go to sam phillips
studio and and make it and that's not
how it happens the first patron you need
to have is yourself
you need to be the one who's going to
finance and fund your dream right so
probably don't quit your job right away
find a way to do it for an hour a day we
all know this we all did this right yeah
like the big jerry maguire moment you
know like that's cool and if you watch
that movie which is fiction by the way
his life still kind of sucks for a while
because cause that's not the best way to
pursue a dream you don't have to take a
leap you can start building a bridge
and i believe strongly in that and so
why do artists struggle i think because
they're believing an old story that
doesn't quite work
today
and they they haven't patronized
themselves they haven't
used their own resources to to believe
in themselves you can fund your own art
and should for a while and then i think
the next thing
is you're not gonna find an audience
right you're gonna find one person i
remember when i started my blog
and i was like i just i'm gonna give
myself two years to get 250 readers and
remember like when you got your first
comment or email oh yeah you were like
holy cow people are listening
i wrote this in my underwear at the
breakfast table you know like this is
crazy
and i know what it's like to be so
uh egocentric that i'm like i don't care
about that one person i want a thousand
people like
artists don't like talking about that
but every artist i know have a few
drinks at a bar like that's what they
want they don't want that guy or that
girl in the front row they want
everybody they want the stadium
the stadium is 10 000 of those
individuals right and i remember i think
it was chris gillabo who said um
you know you want an audience
you should answer every email reply to
every comment until you can no longer do
so
and i remember i would send a weekly
email newsletter and i'd have 20 50 100.
it took me six months to get a thousand
people on my email list and then first
year or so i got about 10 000 people i
had a one-to-one relationship with 10
000 people if you replied to an email
that i sent i responded yeah you know
and i don't
think people realize that you know like
they don't realize that the work of
building an audience is not just playing
the show it's hanging out afterwards and
and talking to the people who liked it
your job as a creative professional is
to find one person who likes it go you
liked it great and find more of those
people yeah
man uh you talking about the um you know
holding strong on the vision but
uh you know being able to kind of have
some flexibility with the details it
makes me think about how josh and i talk
about how you have to have these high
standards but have these low
expectations love that so i would ask
you know buster's daughter like hey what
is what are your standards what are you
holding
uh strong what are you committed to
and the way you get there is not as
important as yeah having that having
that vision i would ask like a couple
things to come to mind i'm like is she
going to open mic nights has she
recorded you know an album to put out
into the world um how often is she
creating because i think a lot of times
artists it's so hard to get this talent
and the talent is so important like you
gotta have a little bit of talent to to
produce art
but that is once you have the talent i
feel like that's only about fifty
percent of your journey the other 50 is
having that vision and making it come to
fruition would you agree with that or
yeah i mean i i i would replace word
talent with skill yeah because talent is
this thing that we think we're born with
and
maybe like uh
most of what we understand about talent
has been debunked there's still still
like especially when it comes like
sports physical sort of performance
there are some outliers but so much of
the science of skill acquisition going
back to malcolm gladwell's outliers has
essentially been debunked uh even
perfect pitch right which was this
musical ability that
people thought you were born with turns
out you can teach kids how to do that if
you get them early enough you can you
can teach a kid to develop perfect pitch
it's possible so the human being is
incredibly plastic neuroplasticity is
the word right like you can they're
moldable right so
yes step one get good right of course
but like get the right kind of good
it's not like what does it mean to be a
good musician you can sing and write
music well
all art is a conversation with culture
it's not just about making cool stuff
all art is about how do how am i
reacting to what's going on in the world
right now
so
don't be stubborn about the kind of art
i mean this might maybe not everybody
agrees with this don't be stubborn about
the kind of art that you think you're
going to create yeah 12 years ago did
you think you would be doing this i
didn't know what a podcast was so no
yeah but also like we didn't think about
i didn't there was no netflix really at
the time right we didn't think about
making documentaries i didn't think
about having a youtube channel didn't
think about the podcast or really social
media to any great extent it was hey we
started this blog and maybe we'll write
some books yeah and the first book we
wrote was a pdf yeah we couldn't even
print books at the time right right but
we were just getting work out there and
so realizing that
the vision itself also can't be so rigid
because then it prevents you from
flowing toward wherever you're going to
go because if my vision was strictly i'm
only going to write book this is my
vision of my 20s i'm going to write
fiction of course i want to write novels
and that's all i want to write and then
of course ryan comes with this idea for
the minimalists and it's like a blog i
don't even know what that is right but
we just started following that path
having a vision but not being so rigid
about it that we weren't willing to
pivot as well yeah it's interesting
because the vision that i've always had
with this is um adding value to other
people's lives yes and you've become
vehicle agnostics
yeah that's great uh here's vision
here's a good vision
i live in kansas a friend of mine who
used to be a technical writer for a big
company johnson and johnson which will
remain nameless
this this episode is actually sponsored
by um i don't know
john cena some cream yeah
[Laughter]
i wanted to be a writer and he worked
for 10 years as a technical writer if
you want to be a creative writer you
don't want to work for a fortune 500
company as a technical writer like you
know it's not fun it's ones and zeros
basically and people
he quit you know he had a year's worth
of salary saved and people asked him all
kinds of questions they said um
what do you got to do about life
insurance and and health insurance and
and and what's your family going to do
and how your kid's going to go to school
and he basically said yo i don't know
yeah right like i've done the best that
i can this has been my dream for 10
years and it's sort of like this
i've lived in kansas my whole life he
didn't live in kansas from pennsylvania
but you know if you if you want to like
like just think of the most you know
normal mundane place you pick kansas
right uh no offense any kansas people no
no no no kansas is a beautiful state by
the way no offense to the canadians
yeah yeah to those yeah um so he said
it's like i've been living in kansas my
whole life and i've always wanted to
live on the beach
and
one day after dreaming of where i'm
gonna go on the beach what kind of my
time i'm gonna have uh what my chair on
the beach is gonna look like this is
where dreams die by the way for creative
people is you think about all this crap
that you think you're gonna do you put
it on your vision board and and you
think you're gonna manifest it and
that's not how dreams get manifested
this is how dreams get manifested the
way my friend did it he quit his job
after adequately preparing writing books
on the side doing this he said i've
wanted to live on the beach my whole
life and i couldn't figure out all the
details so i packed up the van put all
my kids in there and we are driving
towards water
you want a vision you find out what your
water is you find out where you want to
go and the ocean is really big yeah
drive towards water you know in your
life when you are not driving towards
water you can feel it and you also know
when you're stuck at a gas station
trying to figure out the next road to
take it's it's not like that just find
your water and drive towards it that's
so good let's move on to our callers if
you have a question or comment for our
podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
looks like andrea from tucson has a
question for us i
have a lot of artwork from childhood in
high school
that was saved by my parents and then
given to me because they wanted out of
their house and some of its decent
quality
a lot of it is sentimental but i want it
out of my house
i
don't want to display it it doesn't
really serve anything for me at this
point in my life
and i mean i don't want it to go into
the trash but if it does i don't want to
know that it's being thrown away
so do you guys have any ideas of how i
can
um get rid of it
places to give it to
um just anything i just need it out of
my life at this point
all right jeff so this is i obviously
had to bring it back into minimalism in
some way right and so what we're talking
about here is she's created some stuff
in the past that she may not be proud of
doesn't really want but also like she
wants it gone from her life but doesn't
want to get rid of it right that often
happens to many of us this reminds me
to some extent where someone was like i
want to eat meat but i don't want to
kill animals
and and yet so like i'll just pretend
that nothing is going so if someone else
can hide this art for me yeah i think
this is we all sort of have the residue
of our past right and it can haunt us
you even mentioned like oh there's some
things in this book that i i don't like
but you also recognize
that this adds value to people's lives
and so in order for it
to add value to people's lives there's
going to be things that you've created
in the past that
maybe you don't personally get value
from anymore but someone else might this
is more of a decluttering question
though hey i have a bunch of stuff from
the past
that i want to let go of and i'm
terrified of letting go of it should i
hold on to it for posterity or yeah uh
there's two things that come to mind one
is there's a little-known story about
hemingway when he moved to paris
he moved to paris because he was told
that that's where the most interesting
people in the world lived and he wanted
to be a writer and he
had had just
recovered from a wound as an ambulance
driver
he during world war one kind of drove
over this landmine and and
got some uh shrapnel on his leg
and um and he got married moved to paris
uh it was cheap there at the time
uh it is not cheap there anymore um
he moves to paris and he's writing all
the time he's writing these stories and
um
and his wife and he went on a trip
and she she came back from the trip to
meet him and he went back to paris
because he was working for a newspaper
at the time and he had this trunk
full of manuscripts
like like a couple of books that he was
working on and stories and all kinds of
things
and she lost the trunk
and or the trunk got lost and he blamed
her uh which she sold it on ebay
and
what's interesting about that is i mean
this is kind of interesting because
somewhere
or at some point there are these
uh undiscovered hemingway manuscripts
that nobody has ever found that you know
or i don't know they're buried somewhere
they got thrown away or whatever
um and what happened right after that is
he stepped into the most prolific
season of his life he wrote the sun also
rises shortly after that he wrote the
sun also rises in six weeks
and and and that was the book that put
him on the map
uh and made him basically an overnight
sensation and he eventually became uh
one of the 20th century's most famous
and successful authors and you could say
that it started out with unintentional
decluttering
and so i've got sort of two thoughts on
that one is if you really just want to
close your eyes and let go i think it's
okay to like
have somebody take care of that for you
and go hey i don't want to know about it
yeah absolutely um and you guys are the
expert at this more than i am um but i
did just move
and i had 20 years of stuff um because
i'm a very sentimental person i had
letters i had things that i had written
things that people had written me
um going back 20 years and um
and i found it to be
very cathartic to actually go through
these letters uh one by one i mean
hundreds it took me hours and i didn't
like i like looked at you know looked at
them i didn't read all of them but some
of them i i got i i re-encountered the
memory of the experience of where i was
at that time who this person was to me
friend girlfriend parent you know lots
of different relationships
and um
i mean maybe three or four people it
sort of um i was like i still want to be
in touch with that person so i took a
picture of the letter and i texted it to
this person
as just sort of a way to like connect
with them and then i threw the letter
away because i was like this is what i
want i want the connection with the
human not the letter and then i actually
save just a handful of them because you
know they're nice mementos
and um
and that was that was a spiritual
experience i mean you guys know this um
and i wasn't i i wasn't ready for that
until
that point where it was significant to
me i was starting this new chapter of my
life and i kind of said goodbye
to these things while remembering the
memories and holding on to it i know
artwork can be a little bit different
but kind of i mean these were like songs
i'd written in some cases these were
paintings and drawings that i had or
that people had given me and i would say
you know if there's some stuff that you
want you want people to see cool like
maybe go hey friend
take care of this for me
and i do think it could be very
cathartic to go through some of that
stuff
and seth godin told me once when he
decluttered his library he said that his
books are his friends and he still
misses them every day and i as an author
i love that you know uh i recently moved
and i got rid of a lot of stuff in like
10 books you know and the other
9 000 remained
but your works of art are your friends
they're your family they're very
significant to you it's hard to throw
them away
and you can say goodbye to them in a
really beautiful way
um that isn't maybe as traumatic as you
know your
wife showing up at a train station
without you know these these staggering
works of genius you've been working on
and
it's
like it's okay to just go okay see you
later i'm gonna let go of that energy so
i can go right the sun also rises yeah
so i can go i can be free of the energy
because a lot of work that we do early
early on is not good you know i don't
hear you saying this is really really
good stuff that needs to be in a museum
you have to have a lot of reps you've
got to do a lot of stuff and you can
give that stuff away or throw it away or
sell it it doesn't actually matter as an
artist you're trying to get to your best
work as quickly as possible and the best
way to do that is to do a lot of work
and not cling to each single piece of it
last night we were at the comedy store
and we saw this great comedian trying
new jokes i'm gonna try a new joke he he
he read the joke nobody laughed he goes
okay bad joke and this one woman goes i
don't get it he goes well here let me
explain it to you he goes if nobody
laughs though i don't need to explain it
it's dead
you know and you've got to be that
unprecious with your work yeah that's
him letting go and yeah so from a very
practical standpoint
if you need to save something for
posterity
i'm grateful like i know a lot of david
foster wallace's works are collected at
the university of texas at this sort of
but it's all catalog digitally and i
don't need the actual physical artifact
if you ha in fact it's better in many
respects to have the digital version
that way it's backed up
yeah anything like that and so if you
really feel like there's something i'd
like to hold on to for the sake of
archiving it for future generations fine
but the truth is we don't need to
archive most of our second grade artwork
well my mom or my my wife's mom did this
amazing thing for all of her kids you
know they collected a lot of sort of kid
stuff all throughout the the years as
parents often do but what she did in the
last year is she pared everything down
to one box per kid
here are the most sort of sentimental
memories and it created a boundary or a
barrier i can't go beyond this box but
then she handed each kid a very
intentional box and here you go yeah and
so if you want an intentional way to do
this before it gets swept up in a flood
or it just someone else comes and steals
it from your house
doing that on your own curating it in a
way where it fits into a capsule of
sorts and then digitizing the other
things
but you're letting go
so you can move forward you can work on
the future r because if i continue to
cling to the books and the blog posts
and everything else that i wrote in the
past is going to prevent me from doing
anything meaningful going forward yeah
art is an expression of a moment and
it's wonderful to have
a collection of some moments but kids
are incredibly prolific you know what
was interesting to me and i actually
thought about you guys because this just
happened last week i was like all right
kids you know like stuff you want to
donate put in into this box stuff that
just needs to be trashed because you
know like the pieces aren't you know all
together whatever put it in here and
then stuff you want to keep put it in
here uh
my kids didn't have much stuff we've
been living in an apartment for the past
three years and they got rid of about 80
of their stuff oh wow and i was like
hey i gave this to you for christmas
and then yeah i don't use it anymore
that's awesome i was like no no no no no
no wait wait wait wait i'm like this
cost some money it was hard it was hard
for me but you know what's so
interesting about that is
kids are always in the moment they go
well that's from six months ago this is
what's true now and i had a lot of
artwork that my children had made and i
didn't keep all of it because some of it
kind of sucks sorry kids yeah and i
would i would keep the stuff that i
really liked i'll go that that's a cool
picture
that i want to hold on to because this
is an articulation it's a snapshot
of who my daughter was at five six years
old but think of it like this right
life is always happening and you could
take a picture
of life happening right and
one of my favorite spiritual teachers is
a guy named anthony demelo
yeah he's my favorite and he talks about
he goes people go on trips to take
pictures of places they never saw
because you never you never got to slow
down and experience it yesterday we were
out here it's a drake line actually
that sounds right sounds right and it's
like that you know so much of life even
art is holding on to moments that have
already passed now it's okay to take a
picture of a beautiful moment right like
i'm glad that i have some moments
captured but you could go through life
taking pictures of every moment and not
experiencing any of it same is true of
your arts
i think it was bob dylan who said about
blowing in the wind he goes i don't even
know who wrote that
i'm not that guy anymore yes
my friend derek webb
as a musician says when he plays his old
songs he plays them as covers because
he's not that person anymore
you know
and it's like a book it's like oh i
wrote that right gosh
that had to do with what i was reading
how i was sleeping what i was eating
what i was thinking i could never write
that book again that's right you know
and so your art is always an expression
of life
keep living and you will keep making
more art and if you want to hold on to
some stuff and share some stuff cool
and a lot of times the stuff that you
think is awesome people are like ah and
some of the stuff that you think is is
okay people love but keep living keep
creating and keep letting go of the
little articulations of moments that
you've manufactured because there will
be more moments and there will be more
art and most artists who are holding on
to relics of their past are afraid that
they're done and that their best work is
behind them and that is only ever true
when you believe it's true um yeah we
cling out of out of fear we uh we're
running over on time so i'm gonna we'll
save the patreon live stream questions
for the maximal episode this week ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your questions we answer your
text messages you can text those
questions to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now jeff during
the lightning round this is where we and
our guest we try to answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response but don't worry i
have one of your pithy quotes
we call them minimal maxims and podcast
john puts them in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media we have a
question from millie
i am an aspiring artist and no an online
presence is necessary but it's a huge
distraction for me how do i manage
social media when i need it to make
money
so jeff you have this quote on page 10
of your book
this is something pithy before you can
create great art you first have to
create yourself
and you were talking about that a little
bit earlier but one of the things i
think quite often that we
we try to do
is
we try to supplement the creating
process with all of these
empty calories in a way
now you can use social media in a
creative and artistic way there's no
doubt about that but quite often we use
it as an avoidance to keep us from
actually
writing painting
creating filming taking photos whatever
it might be yep you want to expand on
that a bit yeah i would say practically
speaking go deep in one place where you
can do your best work
and then be very intentional about
setting up guard rails to protect the
integrity of that work
that would be about 140 characters
that's good that's fine what i mean by
that is like
your best work might happen on twitter
or it might happen on you know a long
form podcast and it's okay to dabble but
find one place where you can get deep
into the work
and stay there and that's hard because
the whole point of social media is like
this thing and this thing and this thing
but go
show up someplace where you can do
really good work and stay true to that
for a long time yeah yeah i'll uh here's
my pithy answer for you needing a thing
reduces one's ability to enjoy that
thing and i'll say that especially with
social media if you feel as an artist or
creative or a podcast or whatever you
are that you need social media you're
gonna cease to enjoy it in fact it's
gonna feel like a chore uh i have i mean
you hear this also i have to post about
this yeah you don't need social media as
an artist you need a place to practice
right and so if you're a comedian you
should go to the comedy store and just
show up every night and get you know get
on the list because you need a place to
practice in the best artists practice in
public
brian you got some epiphany for us yeah
my fifth answer is the artist's priority
is art
i mean that's that's if you're making
social media a priority well then now
you're you're straying away from what
your actual priority is um you know
people ask go out there like you know
hey ryan uh how do you have a successful
podcast um you know how did you guys
start a successful blog and josh and
i've written about both of those things
but really the secret is consistency
like that's one of the big secrets yeah
consistency we have a blog post uh two
to three times a week we do a podcast
once a week a minimal episode uh and
then one a maximal episode a week
consistently day in and day out people
know exactly what to expect and when i
see a lot of people doing is they start
off really strong because they're
excited about it and then it starts to
become a little bit a little bit mundane
or it's work you know it's it's putting
in the effort there's some sort of
drudgery there there's some drudgery
yeah and they don't drudge through that
drudgery they stop and as soon as they
do that they lose any audience that they
started to gain and
quite frankly a lot of those people
won't come back right away yeah you have
to go back to the consistency so yeah i
mean just being consistent with it is
one of the biggest keys producing or
making the art is is kind of the big
thing i feel like okay i got another
pithy answer yeah let's do it
don't promote practice in public
use social media to create good work
yeah like that's that's it right like
you guys aren't
you aren't making stuff and promoting it
the work itself is the promotion yeah
and you've got to find the right place
to do that that's a great distinction
yeah jeff we got so much more to talk
about i got a couple added value
segments this week nicodemus we'll uh
dive into those you're going to enjoy
this also we have a very special
announcement if you live anywhere in
southern california stay tuned for that
but first alabama what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners hello it is
kit calling from toronto ontario i did
want to comment on meditation as i'm an
individual who is very frustrated at the
beginning of their meditation journey
since i'm somebody who has a monkey mind
and the traditional idea of meditation
the sitting
closing your eyes and clearing your mind
just didn't resonate with me
so i dove a little further did a little
bit of research and i found out that
meditation is actually more about being
in the present moment and once i was
able to wrap my
mind around this concept it was a lot
easier for me to actually have a mindful
practice in everyday life whether i'm
doing the dishes or the laundry any
mundane task can be meditation it's as
long as you're being mindful and you're
being present and you're being aware so
keep in mind that individuals who are
maybe frustrated with the traditional
idea of meditation you can actually
meditate when you're dancing when you're
going to the gym a walk in the park or
even when you're watching tv it can
really be anything that you enjoy as
long as you're present and in the moment
hello i'm lady from brazil and this is
for the lady who asked about minimizing
beauty products first don't let social
media like pinterest and instagram
compel you to consume it's easy to
mistake inspiration with comparison to
me minimalist beauty could be about
enhancing what you have instead of
spending time and money trying to change
it i found freedom in embracing my
natural hair texture and color i found a
hairdresser who knew how to properly cut
my hair type then minimize the time and
money spent trying to change it about
makeup you can minimize the amount of
stuff by owning multi-purpose tools like
a beauty blender that replaced all skin
and concealer brushes for me get rid of
repeated items and throw away expired
makeup as you can grow bacteria and
cause breakouts and don't feel bad if
you paid a lot for something you need to
toss it if buying an item made you happy
it already served its purpose
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment this week and we
have two added values for you that are
amazing we are joined by telephone by
our good friend tk coleman tk what's up
man
what it is how's it going fellas oh
we're just so glad to be among proper
villains
we're happy to have you here we're sorry
we couldn't have you in studio you know
you were supposed to be here today with
jeff goins he missed you but he was a
he you're the reason he was on the
podcast we've known jeff for a long time
we want to say thanks to him by the way
oh yeah he's a great podcast you can
check out his um his book that we talked
about on the podcast and we have tk here
and tk we're starting something special
it's called sunday symposium folks can
find the details at sunday symposium.com
the first one is august 28th it is here
in los angeles now you and ryan and i
but mainly you and ryan had a desire to
start a local community
and i wanted to run this by you on the
phone right now what was the impetus of
of starting this this idea and we'll
talk about the details here in a moment
man well you know i've been working with
you guys pretty closely for the past few
years now and i always enjoy coming into
the studio and just having great
conversation with you
but there was something really special
about being on tour with you guys this
past year
and having the opportunity to interact
with the live audience having the
opportunity to engage them even when
someone is asking a question being able
to ask for clarification or ask for
specificity there is there is a certain
quality of aliveness that comes
from human interaction and there's just
no substitute for it i've always been a
fan of the theater for instance and when
you go to a movie it's great you know
it's all embellished and it's all very
well produced and i love it we should
keep doing that but then there's a
certain kind of magic you get when you
go into the theater because there's risk
the actor might mispronounce a word you
know the audience might laugh one night
but they might cry a different night
over the same scene that spontaneity
that spirituality of human interaction
is just a beautiful thing that we can't
get from
the digital
interaction and i've always been
fascinated with that and when i get a
chance to experience the magic of being
together with you all
and interacting with people i you know
my immediate thought was how can we do
more of this like this is so healing for
all of us how can we do this more
additionally
about 40 percent of americans
claim to be very religious
and
only about a fifth of that audience
actually attends any kind of weekly
church or synagogue
and part of the reason why is just
because you know maybe they don't find
that experience to be relevant
one of the results of that decline in
church attendance is people have thrown
out the baby with the bath water and
they now are divorced from community
having a weekly source of inspiration or
having just a periodic source of
inspiration doesn't have to be every
week but being able to connect with
other people
being able to share in that common
desire to live our best lives and be
healthier versions of ourselves and so
another reason why this is so
interesting to me is because it's a way
for us to help build a community that
isn't about us but about that natural
human longing to connect with one
another and work together to build the
lives that we want to live that's a
mouthful but i'll stop there guys that's
a great place to start you know ryan
came to me one day and he said i'd like
to start a minimalist church without
religion or dogma or ideology well
here's the thing man i'm so
i'm fed up with teaching people what to
believe in when they need to really
believe in themselves and that's what
we're gonna do with this sunday
symposium and that's what we do when we
go on tour it's not about uh preaching
about any specific religion or or or
yeah or dogma whatever it may be it's
about people being able to look at
themselves and and really gain the
emotional leverage they need to do
whatever they need to do in their life
that's right we're gonna start small so
this is a small community i will tell
you this within the first hour of this
podcast coming out it will most likely
be sold out it's a free event
if you can't afford to give a donation
donations are to help us pay for the
venue it's downtown los angeles you can
find all the details at
sundaysymposium.com the very first one
is august 28th if this thing goes well
then we'll continue to do more of these
whether it's monthly quarterly weekly
i'm not exactly sure yet we want to
start small 200 people only if you can
donate great if you can't afford it
that's okay too you can get a free
ticket over at
sundaysymposium.com here's the gist of
it it's a simple gathering for simple
people a local
loving dogma free community kind of like
a church without religion now it's not
to say that religion is bad or but what
we're saying here is all beliefs are
welcome whether you're part of a
religion or all non-beliefs are welcome
as well it's all ages the hugs are free
the conversation's free we're going to
give a talk about simple living we'll do
a discussion between the three of us and
we have a secret guest we might even
have a secret musical guest as well
and uh and then of course
answer your questions we'll do audience
discussion q a whole bunch of surprises
there limited to 200 people it's noon
sunday august 28th
it's a
sundaysymposium.com tickets are free or
pay what you can
so they will sell out quickly t.k you
want to add anything else today
yeah man i mean since religion has come
up so many times i'll just say
uh from my point of view
religion or be a substitute for religion
or any of that kind of stuff this is
about human beings coming together to
create to collaborate to connect and to
work together to create meaningful
experiences and to embrace
the spontaneity and uncertainty of that
we're going to create an opportunity for
us to just facilitate something new and
be open to the possible and that's
really what this is all about oh man
that's
that is beautiful and what i'll say is
that tk ryan and i all have different
religious and spiritual beliefs and so
i don't want you to be turned off by the
idea this isn't like church you're not
coming to a church it happens to be the
same time it's noon on a sunday but this
is for folks who want to attend
something local that is meaningful and
see how it grows from here
tk thank you so much for joining us
today by the way it's my uh my birthday
tomorrow i wrote this essay tk you tell
me what you think it's called
this minimalist once a birthday gift
here's uh here's how it goes 41 is a
fairly unremarkable birthday
too old to be young too young to be
truly wise
but since today june 29th 2022 well
that's tomorrow really it's my 41st
birthday perhaps you can make it more
meaningful
i'm not writing this missive to impart
41 life lessons although if you're
looking for that you can read last
year's 40 life lessons from 40 years
which is an underappreciated gym rather
i'm writing to ask you for a gift so if
you're listening to this podcast
you want to get me a gift from my
birthday i'm actually asking you for a
gift
isn't that ironic ryan this minimalist
wants a gift um now i don't need new
socks cufflinks or a bread maker
guess i'm returning all my gifts then
[Laughter]
so instead of sending me a physical gif
would you be willing to rate and review
the minimalist podcast on apple podcasts
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes that would be the best gift for me
because your review will help our simple
living message reach more ears
now unlike most shows ryan and i don't
continually ask our listeners to rate
and like and subscribe and click the
notification bell every episode because
that feels like audio clutter to us so
hopefully on the rare occasion that we
do ask you'll feel compelled to give us
that gift it takes less than two minutes
and i'd appreciate an apple podcast
review much more than an applebee's gift
card
[Laughter]
i don't need the seed oils in my life
anymore so
if you want to give me something leave
me a review and leave ryan a review on
apple podcast it really does help us we
don't ask you every episode hey please
like and subscribe
avoid the audio clutter this is the one
time of the year i'm going to ask you
it's my birthday if you want to get me a
gift leave us a review applepodcast.com
the minimalists that would really help
us out now tk for our added value
segment this week you know we've got
new sean here we're calling the folks
are calling him prof shawn or professor
sean because he teaches my how to write
better class with me how to write
better.org by the way but that's not our
added value segment this week our good
friend professor shawn his real name is
sean mihalek he has a new novel out
today on june 28th and it is called
lumina i encourage you to check it out
he is a super talented writer a talented
novelist yes sean what is this your uh
fifth book
i it might be my seventh i lose track
holy moly who is this guy colin wright
who lives in track of how many books
he's written this guy a copy of my
resume
[Laughter]
all right so so check out his new book
it's called lumino we'll put a link to
it in the show notes it's his longest
book and he has told me that it is his
best book it's the only one of his i
haven't read yet but i'm looking forward
to reading the physical copy today as
soon as i get it now let me leave you
today with our second added value since
it's the beginning of summer right now
and it's really feeling like summer i
thought i'd play my favorite summertime
song
it's called summertime by the fresh
prince
by the way ryan we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how do
i put an end to my perfectionism so i
can write more
is it possible for me to be creative if
i'm not a creative person how do i make
time to be creative while i'm working a
regular job how do full-time creative
hand how do full-time creatives handle
health insurance
retirement financial planning and other
things traditionally covered by a
nine-to-five job plus a million more
questions for jeff goins and the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalists or subscribe via the
link in the description once you
subscribe you'll get a personal link so
that our weekly private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalist on tick tock instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalists
if you want our podcast show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of jeff
goins ryan nicodemus tk coleman alabama
podcast sean jordan no more professor
sean social jess danny unknown
post-production peter m of the immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
phillips-milburn if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
everybody